welcome to monsters incorporated
they scare because they care pixar's
monsters inc franchise is among one of
their most
celebrated ones like many of pixar's
other films they have plenty of hidden
disney references for fans to look out
for now that the franchise is continuing
with monsters at work
let's take a look at some of the hidden
disney references in both monsters inc
and monsters university hello
i know hey wasn't i great if you look
closely you'll notice that many of boo's
toys seem to share a common theme with
each other some of her toys serve as
references to other pixar films
in the scene towards the end which has
boo handing her toys to sully
you'll notice that jessie the lovable
cowgirl introduced in toy story 2
is lying on boo's tea table hopefully al
doesn't try to take her away
that's me it's out i got an emergency
here another iconic pixar character who
can be found in buu's room had yet to
make his pixar debut
at the time of the film's release nemo
just like jessie is portrayed as one of
boo's toys as well as one that she tries
to give sully towards the film's
conclusion
though this wasn't the only nemo
reference as a painting of a clownfish
can be seen as part of a mural during
the restaurant scene
both of these references are part of a
long-standing pixar tradition where a
reference to the next pixar film is
hidden within the film
well that's very nice pixar's iconic
luxo ball which has appeared in almost
every one of their films has taken on
countless different forms from carpets
to shields
and even a hallucination in monsters inc
it can be found in its original form
lying on buu's bedroom floor among all
her other toys
including nemo and jesse in monsters
university the
famous yellow and blue striped ball can
be seen taking another form
as wall graffiti during the first
challenge of the scare games
this red starred ball sure knows its way
around the world of pixar
in the climax of monsters inc mike and
sully throw randall through a closet
door that transports him to a trailer
home
where he is greeted by its two
inhabitants that mistake him for an
alligator and beat him with a shovel
if that trailer home looked familiar to
you that's because if you are an avid
pixar fan
you will remember that it previously
appeared in a bug's life with a familiar
vehicle parked right next to it
flick and his friends better watch out
for randall pretty crazy huh oh yeah
parked right next to the trailer home is
yet another pixar hallmark
the pizza planet truck which is a call
back to the studio's beloved toy story
franchise
this famous truck has appeared in all
but one of pixar's films
making pizza planet the go-to pizzeria
in all of the pixar universe
the truck is in the same exact spot it
was in a bug's life
sitting right next to the trailer that
randall is thrown into at the end of the
film
in monsters university the pizza planet
truck can be found
parked outside the jock's fraternity
house which is certainly appropriate for
the film's college setting
right here another long-standing
tradition at pixar is the number a-113
an inside joke at the studio over the
name of a classroom at cal art where
many of their top talent got their start
the number has appeared on cereal boxes
roman numerals and street signs over the
course of its history in pixar films
in monsters inc the number can be
briefly seen in the door vault scene
printed on one of the pillars as a-113
meanwhile in monsters university the
number makes an appearance that traces
back to its origins
serving as the room number for a
classroom at the school of scaring
you know where the door is in the scare
floor montage featured in monsters inc
which features a monster running out of
a teenage girl's bedroom
there's a blink and you'll miss it shot
of a paul bunyan poster
this same poster can also be seen in the
bedroom of the villainous
sid in the first toy story film if that
girl was anything like sid there's no
wonder why that monster was so
terrified these days
another easter egg that can be found
during the scare floor montage is the
scareboard
showing off all the monster's scores
with sully and randall featured at the
top
what you may not have realized is that
many of the other names depicted on the
board are the names of pixar employees
these names include joe ramft bud lucky
jonas rivera bob peterson bob paulie
and daniel gerson maybe working at
monsters inc is their second job
i can't believe it during a scene in the
first act where randall is showing off
his camouflage abilities one of the two
backgrounds that appears is a brick wall
while the other background is a direct
callback to another classic pixar film
the familiar looking cloud wallpaper is
the exact same design as the one used in
andy's room in the toy story films
does this mean randall is andy's monster
hey look at that it's randall
another hidden reference in monsters
university can be found on uzma kappa
president don carlton's business card
that he proudly touts to mike and sully
if you look closely you'll see that the
address printed on the card is 1200 dark
ave
which sounds almost identical to pixar's
real address
1200 park ave maybe don carlton worked
in sales at the monster version of pixar
before heading back to college at
monsters u
but he's right another numerical
reference lies within the opening scare
simulation scenes in monsters inc the
number 510
752 3000 can be seen on the control
panel that miss flint uses
this is not just any old number it was
actually the phone number for pixar
animation studios at the time of the
film's release
that makes you wonder if they got a lot
of phone calls monsters inc
please hold monsters inc i'll connect
you in the penultimate scene of monsters
inc which finds mike performing a comedy
routine in front of a young boy
avid disney fans may recognize a
familiar poster in the bedroom
if you look closely you'll see a poster
behind the boy for tomorrowland
one of the most popular themed areas in
all of disney parks
the area even spawned its own movie
directed by pixar veteran
brad bird your room where you from
in the final scene of monsters inc
taking place at the newly established
laugh floor
one of the comedic props that can be
seen lying around in the background is a
red unicycle
this is actually a reference to pixar's
second cg short titled red dream
which follows a lonely red unicycle who
dreams of finally being able to get his
chance in the spotlight
hopefully red's appearance on the laugh
floor means his dream
finally came true one can hope i hope we
get a copy of that tape
one of pixar's most notable traditions
is having actor john ratzenberger make
an appearance in almost every single one
of their films in roles of various sizes
he voiced key roles like ham and toy
story and mac in cars
as well as small parts like the school
of fish and finding nemo
and a construction worker in onward some
even call ratzenberger pixar's
unofficial good luck charm to their
success
ratzenberger unsurprisingly makes an
appearance in both monsters inc
and monsters university as the yeti he
is even reprising the role in the series
monsters at work where he'll also be
voicing the father of the main character
tyler tuskman who knows what other kinds
of characters john
ratzenberger will voice in future pixar
projects
all right newbies quit goofing around
monsters university continued pixar's
tradition of hinting at their next film
with a quick reference to the good
dinosaur which at the time was set to be
their next film
before its release date was eventually
pushed back during the final challenge
of the scare game sequence
toy versions of several of the
characters from the film can be seen on
the floor of the bedroom simulation
thanks for taking it easy on grandpa
both monsters inc
and monsters university have plenty of
hidden disney goodies for fans to enjoy
when they revisit the films
before reuniting with mike and sully in
monsters at work
from pixar hallmarks like john
ratzenberger and the pizza planet truck
to references to toy story and finding
nemo there's plenty to explore
what was your favorite disney reference
in monsters inc or monsters university